[Music]
all right so as we just reported moments
ago sources are telling me tonight the
FBI has in fact completed their
background check on judge Cavanaugh all
100 senators and nine staff members will
have access to that report which will be
kept in a safe at the Senate Judiciary
Committee this comes as the chairman of
that committee chuck Grassley is
sounding the alarm about obstruction
coming from Professor Ford's extremely
bitterly partisan legal team now this
week we told you about this the
Judiciary Committee requested access to
material evidence of Professor Ford's
sexual misconduct claims including notes
from her therapy sessions that she
already had handed over to the
Washington Post any recordings of her
polygraph tests and professor Ford's
attorney are flatly denying the Senate
Judiciary request so much for a real
investigation and tonight in a letter
Grassley fired back he wrote quote the
Constitution tasks the Senate not the
media or the FBI with providing advice
and consent for Supreme Court nominees
it is beyond disappointing that dr.
Ford's attorneys were willing to share
evidence with the Washington Post many
weeks ago but to this day refused to
share the same evidence which dr. Ford
relied on in her testimony with the US
Senate it's important to remember that
Ford's attorney Deborah Katz as you see
on the screen she is a far left huge
big-time Democratic donor remember she
was the one that was recommended by
Dianne Feinstein who wouldn't tell the
Republicans about the whole issue for
weeks and weeks app there two weeks
after and once vowed to resist Donald
Trump we've shown you that tape on ABC
cats has not been cooperative with the
committee from the very beginning
stalling whenever and however possible
and according to Professor Ford's sworn
testimony her attorneys never even
released numerous and persistent
attempts from Senator Grassley and
Republicans to arrange an interview with
Senate Judiciary investigators Deborah
Katz is not to be trusted
her motivations again recommended by
Dianne Feinstein have long been
political including multiple instances
where she defend
Bill Clinton and creepy Al Franken from
their misconduct allegations she even
made light twice of Paula Jones
accusations against Clinton saying that
Jones post she suffered no repercussions
in the workplace because the incident
only lasted 10 to 12 minutes he exposed
himself in front of Paula Jones and he
wanted a sexual favor
I thought Dianne Feinstein recommended a
lawyer thought this woman was supposed
to be a champion of women's rights it
appears that's only true for Democratic
women and meanwhile professor Ford is
facing some allegations of her own and a
written declaration to the US Senate a
man who was professor Ford's longtime
boyfriend between 1992 and 98 is raising
serious issues about her testimony
tonight during the hearing Ford claimed
to have issues with confined spaces
riding in airplanes homes with only one
door because of PTSD symptoms
surrounding her alleged sexual assault
according to a former boyfriend whose
name has been redacted Ford never
expressed these issues with small spaces
she frequently flew in airplanes to and
from Hawaii lived in a small five
hundred square foot apartment with only
one door never mention anything about
being assaulted he also claimed the Ford
once counseled a friend on how to pass a
polygraph test probably to a job
interview with the FBI claimed that
friend is denying now remember during
Fords testimony she emphasized her total
inexperience with polygraphs and
naturally ABC CBS well they totally
ignored the story during their morning
coverage that is called bias of omission
shouldn't shock us now meanwhile in case
of just plain bias the Daily Caller is
reporting that three different NBC news
stories on judge Cavanaugh three of them
faced huge accuracy issues by the way
Andy lack Tom Brokaw are you proud of
your network Tom Brokaw the brand you
spent a lifetime building are you happy
now to be an arm of the Democratic Party
and as you can see the left does not
care about evidence due process
presumption of innocence the
Constitution none of it they don't even
care what this impending
FBI report will uncover or not uncover
Dianne Feinstein doesn't want to even
show it to you
almost all Democrats have been against
Brett Kavanaugh who or whoever the
president would have chosen from day one
there were only now pretending to care
about allegations against Cavanaugh
because they want to still stall the
confirmation vote to them sadly this is
about power and political gamesmanship
whether or not Cavanaugh is guilty it
makes no difference in the Democrats in
this pursuit of power something by the
way even Spartacus himself Senator Cory
Booker admitted to during a recent
interview take a look so my hope is that
just beyond the vicious partisan ranker
that is going on beyond the accusations
we don't lose sight of what this moral
moment is about in this country and
ultimately ask ourselves the question is
this the right person to sit on the
highest court in the land for a life
time appointment ultimately not whether
he's innocent or guilty this is not a
trial but ultimately have enough
questions be raised that we should not
move on to another candidate if enough
questions are raised well you can't get
on the court is that now the new modern
Democratic Party guilty as long as
there's enough accusations guilty of all
charges regardless of what the evidence
shows this is so reckless think of where
this can take us and if what cory booker
said is the new standard well guess what
Spartacus you shouldn't even be a
senator based on your own standards in
your own words remember you once bragged
about your own sexual assault as a young
man writing about groping a woman in
high school even after she said no
pushed you away by by Spartacus I guess
it's time for you to leave the US Senate
in shame now that's why we call them the
party of smears this is why I keep
bringing up the idea of slander and lies
and character assassination and family
bludgeoning all for political power over
sacrificing the rule of law and justice
things we should all hold deeply that
should not be political as we speak
they're doing anything and everything to
stall scared Senator Jeff snowflake and
others into voting against Cavanaugh's
nomination they're now moving the bar as
much as they can well maybe it's about
temperament not about what the FBI says
and now as we predicted their new
talking point is the current FBI inquiry
is being rushed we don't trust the FBI
just despite absolutely no requests from
the FBI that more time is needed at all
it's all about delay now we're going to
talk about temperament now we're going
to talk about well maybe he didn't tell
us exactly exactly how much he drank
even though he said he drank a lot a
beer and still drinks beer and sometimes
drank too much beer what's this
I trust the FBI I hope they have the
latitude the time in order to get the
job done right the Republicans held up a
seat when Justice Scalia passed away for
nearly a year so there is no reason to
ram this through there should be a full
investigation of all of the allegations
that have been raised and whatever other
witnesses follow on as a result of the
discussion or the interviews of those
witnesses the Senate should allow the
FBI to pursue all the evidence and not
to cap where they may go or put a leash
on the investigation the FBI is very
close to wrapping its investigation in
fact it could wrap as early as today
does that strike you as sufficient time
or does that feel rushed that no more
time we want more time let's change the
topic let's talk about something else
let's investigate this or that last
minute investigations so yet in another
last-ditch effort to smear judge
Cavanaugh destroy his family Senate
Democrats are demanding the Senate
Judiciary Committee retract the
following tweet quote nowhere in any of
these six FBI reports which the
committee has reviewed on a bipartisan
basis was there ever a whiff of any
issue at all related in any way to
inappropriate sexual behavior or alcohol
abuse Senate Democrats revealed zero
evidence over why that tweet should be
redacted and the Senate Judiciary
be fired back quote nothing in the tweet
is inaccurate or misleading the
committee stands by its statement which
is completely truthful more baseless
innuendo more false smears from Senate
Democrats as you can see the Democratic
Party they are the smear machine now in
full gear and a full panic they don't
want this vote it's really despicable to
watch think about what this means for
your kids and your grandkids and the
future of this country guilt by
accusation enough accusations you're
done now that is why they are flailing
then there's all these questions now
let's talk about his temperament forget
the FBI report we demanded how is
someone accused get this think of this
yourself you're accused of
systematically regularly drugging young
teenage girls being involved in well
frequent gang raping of young teenage
girls what is the proper reaction what
should the temperament be of somebody if
you're falsely accused what would you
expect them to say very quietly I'm
innocent
or do you think they would have such
indignation righteous indignation anger
an outrage that they want to make it as
clear as possible they're innocent I
think the latter is how most people
would probably react and the far-left
mob they're in overdrive remember Maxine
Waters get in their faces well guess
what Maxine it's happening breaking
tonight a congressional intern for
Democrat Sheila jackson-lee
has been arrested after he publicly
posted sensitive information a pro
Cavanaugh Republican senators online
this is extraordinarily dangerous and
over the weekend we saw senator Mitch
McConnell accosted in an airport after
Ted Cruz after Pam Bondi after secretary
Nielson after you know Sarah Sanders
yesterday Republican congressman was
actually assaulted in his Capitol Hill
office by an angry group of protesters
who pushed in his door in Texas another
angry mob confronting a group of pro
Cavanagh students at UT Austin take a
look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you want this kind of behavior rewarded
what do you think the outcome is it'll
be more and more radicalism more and
more allegations make enough of them and
you get your way
basically mob rule no law and order now
do you care about due process in the
presumption of innocence because those
three Republicans we have of course
Susan Collins Lisa Murkowski Jeff
snowflake you're the ones that are going
to decide because if you go along with
this after you got what you wanted this
is what your future and our future is
the country will be now Republicans won
an election we had a president that
actually gave the names of the people he
would consider appointing to the Supreme
Court and he won people want originalist
constitutionalist confirmed for the
Supreme Court that's what they voted for
look at this Fox News poll that just
came out the answer is yes Republicans
are now making gains in top Senate races
all across the country and Republican
enthusiasm has now increased
significantly look at your screen these
are the people who will decide the fate
of Judge Calvin or the future of the
country you want to call these people
feel free to do so call their office
call the hotline call the main line I'd
urge you to be polite I think that's I
think that's respectful of the office
thirty four days from tonight and we'll
know the results of the midterms those
five senators they choose to go along
move the bar stop Cavanaugh because of
what our uncorroborated allegations in
every case no evidence and every
case you know what's gonna happen they
vote against Kavanagh and guess what
they're up for re-election vote and you
can vote them out this is about whether
or not we want to live in a country the
United States of America where smears
are rewarded and America where we accept
character assassination on a regular
basis where we have no problem
destroying political lives with no
evidence no corroboration and it can
happen to you an America where we throw
out all due process out the window we're
willing to reward this behavior and if
Lisa Murkowski Susan Collins Jeff
snowflake if they try and make this
about anything other than what they
asked for a limited FBI report that is
now complete I will say they have zero
character or honor themselves and they
will be responsible as this happens
again and again and again because the
Democrats they don't have a plan listen
to any of them what are they saying that
they will do to improve the country all
you get from the Democrats is we know
they want to impeach 45 they want
impeachment they want endless
investigations into Trump and even
Cavanaugh if he gets on the court they
want to impeach him they want their
crumbs back they want higher taxes they
want to get rid of ice they want open
borders they want leftist judges that
that legislate from the bench they want
Obamacare how's that working out for you
that's their agenda in 34 nights you
head to the polls you get to vote in
House races take a look on your screen
see if that's your district because if
it is it matters and ask yourself one
question is America better off than we
were two years ago you know when you
vote one of these Senate races that you
see on your screen take note from the
economy to security and national
security and trade deals and eliminating
burdensome regulation the biggest tax
cut in history and all of these things
well that's all going to come to a halt
if Republicans lose in November you
don't vote you will get the government
you deserve and if these lawmakers give
in to this tactics it'll happen again
and again
and again you will be rewarding reckless
irresponsible absolutely outrageous
behavior and character assassination you
want to be a part of that you choose in
34 days